well there's a tremendous amount of
exciting things going out of business i
think the breakthroughs in health care
that i participated in what can be done
to improve human health the
contributions of technology to many of
our business and making them more
competitive on a global scale but i
would say of all the things the thing
i'm most excited about is the emergence
of great global and corporations
companies that can operate anywhere in
the globe take advantage of the best
skills everywhere so I'm not a believer
in the criticism outsourcing of those
things I think if we can blend together
in a multicultural sense people of all
kinds of ethnic backgrounds religious
backgrounds racial backgrounds gender
and have that kind of unit we can
organization can make contributions to
tough global problems whether its global
poverty economic self-sufficiency I'm a
great believer in capitalism i refer
with capitalist and I think the
capitalistic model can work if we can be
a collaborative capitalism or what
nirianna Murthy of emphasis calls
compassionate capitalism one that
emphasizes fairness decency transparency
and honesty if that can be blended in
with the principles of capitalism then I
think you have the benefit for using
capitalism to create a better society
however there's a downside to capitalism
and capitalism run a muck can create
great damage and great harm to people
that's why we need authentic leaders
running our organizations not people
that are in it for themselves
well business faces enormous problems
going forward a lot of companies are not
adapted to being in a truly global world
and they're still fighting against it
they haven't they haven't created multi
cultural environments that's certainly
one thing a lot of companies are
fighting against governments and not
recognize their problems a lot of
companies are so short-term oriented in
their financial orientation and
financial performance that the destroy
the very essence of the company and they
don't realize that the only way or
shareholder value is created is by
creating customer value and sustainable
customer value and so business faces all
those risks and if business pushes
beyond the bounds of what society is
looking for that I think business will
be increasingly constrained and then we
can't let the best side of capitalism
which is creating new companies new jobs
new products and services that can help
people really flourish but I think
moving away from a sense of purpose or
making money the only purpose which
we've seen over the last 15 years has
become very damaging money or if you
will wealth creation should be the
resultant it shouldn't be the purpose
the purpose should be creating a product
or service that makes a difference in
society or in the lives of others or
make this a better place to live as a
result if you do that well then you'll
be financially well well rewarded